les manifestations suivies par nos
reporters estelle forgé lucas dg du
cannet g que l'on retrouve tout de suite
luca bonjour alors vu juillet pour nous
la manifestation qui est parti il ya
environ une heure de place de la
bastille quelle est l'ambiance
actuellement
eh bien il ya des milliers de personnes
ici qui défilent dans les rues de paris
principalement des gilet jaune ce sont
des groupes de gilet jaune qui ont
appelé à manifester depuis à bastille
vous l'avais dit il ya plusieurs appels
à manifester ils veulent manifester
contre les lois liberticides en premier
lieu desquels et bien l'extension du
pass sanitaire a annoncé par emmanuel
maquet le 12 juillet ils disent qu'ils
n'en veulent pas je sais pas si vous
pouvez l'entendre derrière moi ils me
disent de très fort je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants que j'ai
pu avoir tout à l'heure au début de
cette manifestation
[Musique]
la vaccination chacun doit avoir le
droit de le faire ou pas enfin c'est pas
le problème mais le problème c'est que
ils veulent à mettre une fille gré
gassion parmi la population
en fait c'est juste un passage c'est
pour nous diviser ensuite le passé à
l'état ce sera pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui depuis la location du
président à public le 12 juillet c'est
un tournant de notre histoire
des gens se sont battus pour la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
aujourd'hui ces prix jeunes a tourné en
cause aujourd'hui en apposant passani
car les gens sont libres de choisir de
se faire vacciner mais pas imposer un
passé ni d'air progressivement on va se
retrouver dans une dictature pure et
dure comme en corée du nord à dose
homéopathique sans qu'on s'aperçoive
l'aïe
ils veulent nous obliger à nous vacciner
il commence par certains fonctionnaires
soient des accents enfantins au contact
des arts à finir par toute la population
ces manifestants ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'espoir dans les institutions pour
arrêter cette loi ils considèrent plutôt
que c'est la mobilisation dans la rue
qui permettra de faire plier le
gouvernement il y avait eu la semaine
dernière 114 mille personnes dans les
rues en france selon le gouvernement
mais en réalité pour ces manifestants eh
bien ils étaient beaucoup plus nombreux
merci